Trump is adored by his followers Dave
Chappelle explained why this is from uh
Dean obadala I think you mentioned you
knew him Dave I used to do stand up with
him let's just leave it at that ah okay
well I'll I'll put it simply like you
have the story here and uh it's amazing
let me read a little bit they say
Chappelle pivoted about halfway through
his monologue the topic of trump
remarking that quote I'm watching the
news now and they're declaring the end
of the Trump era he then melded his
acerbek Kami with a simple truth that
everyone wishing Trump would disappear
from at the from the political landscape
needs to hear Trump's base hasn't come
close to abandoning him I'm just being
honest with you I live in Ohio amongst
the poor whites a lot of you don't
understand why Trump was so popular and
very loved
he goes on a mansion Trump says I know
the system is rigged because I use it
the comedian then joked about how Trump
accused during the debate with Hillary
Clinton of not paying taxes and shot
back that makes me smart
Chappelle shared that for many
working-class Americans struggling to
make ends meet Trump's honesty in
revealing the rich and Powerful have
been taking full advantage of a system
designed for their benefit only enhanced
his stature
it's amazing and then he said Chappelle
pointed out that Trump looked at her and
said and you won't change the laws
because the peop because your friends
benefit from it too and when I heard
Dave Chappelle say that I'm like that
wasn't a joke that wasn't anything other
than powerful insight and a sales pitch
when I heard him say that it reminded me
of of the 2016 uh election what Trump
was on about and then I was just like
yeah I kind of like that he really made
me he really created a positive image of
trump they say Trump's going to announce
his running tomorrow and the weekend
before Chappelle comes out and says this
thing Trump did which is really sad
which is really really good people
respect I'm like
Wow's comments were very close to what
Michael Moore said in 2016 specifically
when it came to Middle Americans and
blue collar workers going for Donald
Trump because he represented the larger
ideas of the American working class
which he was representatively standing
up for but that then Dave Chappelle also
made a joke about Donald Trump taking
out his Illuminati card sniffing some
cocaine and then telling everyone how
they're playing the game and then went
inside to the White House and then
started playing the game which I thought
was also another important point there
but this could be one reason why he's
being criticized as quote anti-semitic
and and promoting uh anti-Semitism right
now by the ADL which I think is
absolutely ridiculous what he mentioned
in his comedy skit I think was perfectly
navigating a very sensitive topic he hit
everyone he made everyone laugh about a
very tough issue and I think his
representation of what happened to Kyrie
Irving and Kanye West was also something
important a couple days ago on my
members area I was talking about how
Dave Chappelle was on Oprah talking
about how people were trying to drug him
so he had to escape the huge contract
that he was under and literally went to
Africa this is also something very
similar that happened to Kanye West so
there's something to really think about
here when it comes to people who are
anti-establishment people who are
breaking from The Matrix people who are
coloring outside of the box I don't know
being heavily criticized and attacked
well look you color outside the box on
anything and they're going to come for
you remember when Rogan had Dr Malone on
what happened the week after the entire
mainstream media is saying Rogan is a
racist and they're releasing all these
videos him saying the n-word not because
he was actually racist but because he
was making fun of the user of the people
that use the n-word but that's what the
system does but I think actually what
you said about the timing is most
interesting because it's like wait a
minute we all saw that in 2016. I didn't
support Trump in 2016 I did vote for him
in 2020 and there's certainly a chance
I'll vote for him again next time if
that's where we're at but it's
interesting because Chappelle he must
have known that then and yet in the same
monologue Chappelle says I think he said
twice I'm a Democrat yep so it's like
well hey what still makes you a Democrat
I don't I don't really get that or maybe
that's his way of just throwing a little
something so that he's not
ousted immediately from the power
structure or something like that but
also it's like where were you for these
last six years when Trump was doing all
of those things that you're crediting
him for like that was day one stuff
right so it's one of those things where
it's like all right you got to the party
so there's the the IQ well there's the
IQ bell curve thing of trump I think
where actually that's probably a bad way
to put it but when you start to really
dig in dig in deep into Trump's
Administration you get a little soured
by it like John Bolton and um and and I
think Bolton was because of Sheldon
Adelson he was getting money from when
you when you actually look at the dark
nitty-gritty you're like my view of it
is the Trump Administration uh I said
this before Trump was the best president
of our lives that doesn't mean he was a
good president you know whether you
think he is or not is entitled to you my
point was that name another president in
my lifetime in our lifetimes who did a
better job the economy was great he was
getting our troops out of the Middle
East the foreign policy was was
generally improving Abraham Accords
peace with North Korea and I'm like that
was all good enough for me in 2020 to
say I will vote for him because I don't
like voting against people look we had
all-time lowest black unemployed women
all-time lowest Latino unemployment the
moment for me that like really kind of
started the shift because it took a
while because everybody kind of has
their own little journey to to get there
for me was that that uh State of the
Union Address when he's talking about
Lois all-time black and Latino
unemployment and then they flash to the
Congressional Black Caucus and they're
sitting there with scowls on their faces
and it's like wait a minute I thought if
you guys want one thing it might be for
black people to have jobs but they hated
Trump more than that they hated him more
than that they they hate you so much
they will vote for John fetterman
that's but that's that people walked
into I'd say they walked into a booth I
guess nobody walks into a booth anymore
people go to the Dropbox or whatever
they do they mail in their 18 ballots to
vote for fetterman how profoundly insane
is that it's this simple Dr Oz poor guy
he had it all think about Nancy Pelosi
and I know everybody watching this save
for a small minority who for some reason
are watching do not like this woman
despise this woman imagine who you would
be willing to support to get rid of her
some bad people right but you know she's
worse right
you look at fetterman and they weren't
looking at Dr Oz like it was Dr Oz and
that's probably why Trump thought Oz
could win they looked at Oz and they saw
Trump and so they just said magabad
Republican bad if Trump's behind it we
vote for the other guy no matter what so
despite the fact that fetterman
he's got severe serious brain damage
yeah they wanted it but but I will I
will also stress too
um because I pointed this out and I
think you probably agree Republicans are
never going to win again so long as
universal mail-in voting is is the rule
of the land because people who are
disinterested from voting who normally
don't care are having ballot Harvesters
knock on their door and say did you fill
that out come on just fill it out yep
then they do
then I put in the mailbox or the ballot
Harvester collects it and a person who
normally wouldn't vote and has no
interest in voting is now voting and
it's creating this ignorant voter base
that votes just by by letter well let's
say most likely everyone watching this
can agree that to some extent there's
something Shady going on there so let's
hit it from the other angle the other
angle would be well what's going on in
Florida the great free state where I
live in Florida they cleaned it all up
and you gotta show an ID it was such a
freaking pleasure to vote in Florida to
go the after I've lived in L.A for a
long time no there were long lines
actually it was pretty functional went
right in school a smiley person standing
outside to walk right this way used an
actual pen paper actually put it in a in
a little folding envelope and walked it
over dropped it in the booth myself
somebody else said Thank you checked an
ID it was like Wow democracy actually
can work some of this can have some
value as opposed to La where you just
drive down Ventura Boulevard you just
yell out who your name you know yell it
out to the crack dealer and then they
whisper it and they vote Newsom long
lines Arizona machines not working
that's insane they still haven't figured
out who won
absolutely crazy did they fail math
Banana Republic [ __ ] when when literally
five days later or whatever no five days
what am I saying it's now we're seven
days out basically well again one of the
reasons why Florida got it right is
because back in 2000 when the election
wasn't counted on Election night people
lost their ish people were freaking out
now it's slowly being normalized which
is absolutely crazy but after that Gore
Bush debacle in Florida the state of
Florida invested a lot of money into
voting uh Ron DeSantis also specifically
passed the law Banning Zucker bucks in
what he called specifically money from
Facebook uh into Florida and I think
that also made a very big impact on the
state because Mark Zuckerberg spent
hundreds of millions of dollars making
sure that there was mail-in ballots
ballot harvesting and all that money all
that financing wasn't available in
Florida because Ron DeSantis stopped it
and I think that is what helped him win
here when almost everyone else lost Tim
do you think that part of it is also
that they want people to not have faith
in the system so they love all of this
not just because they're doing it better
than Republicans but it's also to break
the average person to just be like none
of it works I don't care just give me
some stuff and I'll stay home and
that'll be that like yeah no one ever
said it was going to be easy and I had
someone Super Chat they were like Tim
you told me to get all my friends and go
vote and I did and look what we got and
I'm like you won the projection right
now like the heart protection is 219 in
the house I mean hey maybe in a week the
mail-in ballots will come and the
Republicans will not have one but uh
fortify they got fortified but but if
you didn't go tell your friends to vote
you'd be doing way way worse it is
difficult and here's what the Democrats
would love and the the Neo the neocon
established Republicans as well they
would love it if everyone listening just
said I give up yeah because then
they don't got to worry anymore they say
great you've given up and now we own it
and we'll own you forever well it's the
ultimate black pill it's why I try to do
my show at the end I always try to give
some kind of positive thing at the end
because otherwise otherwise what are we
all doing right we're all talking about
these issues we're trying to I mean
you're a great example of it because you
moved a couple times to places to do the
work that you wanted to do because right
you could you didn't want to do it in
Jersey you didn't feel safe there
anymore
New York right yeah they murdered those
two cops in front of my house that was
go yup so you you did it you took your
foot vote you took all the value that
now you create here and it's like people
need to know that there is a a place
that they can go to that is still
functional Florida is that as DeSantis
called it on Election night that is the
Citadel right now Texas has obviously a
version of it Tennessee does and a
couple other places thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at Tim cast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time